Daripada teleskop kepada Large Hadron Collider,
setiap alat saintifik baru akan semak semula soalan-soalan
yang kami sebagai saintis
dan minda yang ingin tahu boleh tanya secara munasabah.
Pengkomputeran berprestasi tinggi atau HPC
menyertai senarai elit tu pada tahun enam puluhan. Hari ini,
komputer kuantum sedang mengetuk pintu yang sama.
Selamat datang. Nama saya Iskandar Setiawan Kafi,
dan saya jurutera perisian di sini di IBM Quantum.
Dalam kursus ini kami bertujuan untuk ajar pelajar
dan profesional tentang bagaimana quantum computing tak lama lagi akan
bekerjasama dengan infrastruktur HPC
untuk hasilkan pengkomputeran.
Kamu akan belajar bagaimana quantum
dan komputer klasik berkomunikasi dan bertukar data,
cara tulis program yang eksploitasi kedua-dua jenis perkakasan,
dan bagaimana integrasi ini membuka aplikasi baharu yang kita boleh selesaikan hari ini.
Kamu akan bina pengalaman praktikal dengan perkakasan quantum sebenar
dan kluster pengkomputeran berprestasi tinggi klasik,
jalankan kerja quantum bersama beban kerja HPC tradisional,
dan belajar tafsir keputusan dengan yakin,
serta kenal pasti tempat di mana pecutan quantum
boleh bantu pengiraan dengan betul-betul,
dan di mana ia tak membantu. Yang paling penting, kamu akan faham
ke mana hala tuju komputer masa depan
dan peta jalan yang akan bawa kita ke sana. Kami rasa
kursus ini penting
dan tepat pada masanya, dan kami percaya
menggabungkan teknologi-teknologi ini akan jadi penting
untuk capai kelebihan pengkomputeran.
Ini boleh beri kesan yang meluas merentasi pelbagai industri,
seperti kimia yang mungkin membolehkan
reka bentuk ubat dan penyelidikan bahan yang lebih pantas,
dalam kewangan
untuk model risiko yang lebih bijak,
dan pengesanan penipuan, dalam kecerdasan buatan dan pembelajaran mesin
untuk pengoptimuman model. Dalam kursus ini,
kami akan selami dalam-dalam sumber komputer,
model pengaturcaraan dan algoritma quantum.
Jadi selamat datang dan bersiap sedia,
banyak yang nak dibincangkan.